where are you where did you go what
number am I thinking of between 55 and
77 64 is that number and you got it by
default five-minute game here we go Game
one all right I was already ready to
double those points there no button for
that already the English I've been
playing the bad Vinick system quite a
bit for white lately we're going to have
a Catalan we saw the Catalan in the 2013
candidates tournament the ongoing
candidates tournament tomorrow being a
rest day so okay let's see just go with
some normal development this is um mmm
if I could take this pawn and hang onto
okay now this is a bit different I think
now my pond with this pond on this
square after I capture my opponents
going to have to do what they're going
to have to either capture their king or
their night this would not be a good
form of a gambit so pawn takes pawn
takes take the Queen the night I'm
assuming is the one who retreats my only
concern in that variation is that with
that with this pond absent this Bishop
is a bit more influential will I be able
to get my light square Bishop working
that's my only concern pawn takes pawn
takes exchange Queens Knight comes out
you know what I think I could just play
knight c6 or you know what maybe c5
maybe c5 right now no later later I'll
do that so the Queen's are off Queens
are often i'm going to play see five and
then
knight c6 and i think i have no ooh now
that is something i did not expect so my
pony is really going to try to hang on
to this no way no way what about see 6b
five we're just knight c6 and if this
pond is threatened i could play Knight
a5 are not so fast actually knight c6 if
the Queen comes out to tack this that's
dropping this pond so actually I think
this is a good idea i'm a bit hesitant
to be blocking in my sepan that's that's
one of my concerns when I'm bringing my
night out to c6 for sure and this is
very awkward blocking an essential pun
so that said I think I think I want to
hit that Bishop right away night here
because not with the pond being
supported maybe queen here to take the
pond is available if i play a six and
think I can meet Queen a4 with b5 a
mistaken because Knight takes rook here
Quino this still isn't working I think
just night here if the mutton my night
is captured I definitely take with my
pond and now okay I'm picking up the
bishop hair this Bishop is cooked do I
really want that though give this play
on this file builds the center um just
take the bishop right they takes Bishop
Bishop air
hmm
yeah I'm going to take that guy I'm
gonna get my night out of the way the
main reason for this is to get this c5
advanced in and I'm okay with giving
that pond back i just i'm really looking
right now to open up the position i want
to break down these ponds I want to get
on this diagonal at an opportune moment
there is pressure on f7 by both tonight
and night in Brooks so he can't go too
far but I'm assuming this night is just
on its way to pick up this pond and I
think that's what my opponent should be
going forward with okay 83 all right go
here and now I'm threatening a fork this
needs to be addressed right away okay I
got to take with the pond soap on takes
Bishop recaptured after pawn takes the
queen of Bishop are converging on d5 I
could just ignore it though I could just
take right away and be on this pond the
position is opening up I have the bishop
pair and my opponent is still down upon
they do have play in the F file that's I
guess my biggest concern I just take
that pawn bishop here just take that
pond I think I like just bishop right
here develop pressure on this but it's
not an issue and now I have an
additional defender for f7 pawn takes
I'm more than happy to be recapturing
and pinpointing what would then be two
double isolated ponds so follow up moves
I think Queen here is my first thought
just clean here there's no tricky stuff
with the night I do have this square
covered by my bishop and this is the
last piece that I need to really get
working so it's a good idea I think I
just want to reinforce my center I
wanted to play here first actually
because its opposite the queen but uh
fine with this I i really want to kick
that night away that rook is up I think
this rook is close to being
trapped hang on a second pod push rook
here my opponent really looking for me
is that what they were looking to but
what about Bishop here hang on I bishop
could do something else Bishop could
definitely do something outside I don't
if I played f6 rook there was available
and I am a bit uncomfortable i'm moving
another pond a minute 10 i have to look
for a way to convert this [ __ ]
recaptures my queen is unprotected there
might be some tactics and now there's
not going to be any tactics however this
could maybe be taken but after i capture
this the rook the rook is close to being
trapped okay there could be rook here I
want to just take this rook I'm going to
take it I know it's an imbalance
position there is probably a cleaner way
but I want to be able to find pieces for
me oh man imma be able to find homes for
my pieces that's what I meant to say and
from here this Bishop dominates the
night if the night doesn't have a good
place to move the bishop isn't going to
be doing anything and now these ponds I
think I just keep rolling with them 47
two minutes 47 to to just keep pushing
my palms if you're going to give your
queen up you have to have what exactly
the number one thing is coordination
okay let's just protect this pawn bishop
here to attack the pond I would just
push the king is in danger recapture
with the pot of the rock i'm going to
capture the rook because i just want to
get this guy working and it's back up
grab this pond once again staying
coordinated the bishop once again boxing
out the night i feel like i could even
give up the exchange somehow if the
night comes back maybe just double night
takes or up on recaptures and then
deflect the clean off of a the d 2
square somehow although there's got to
be something much simpler i think if
there's a color complex to be focused on
or
that I can rely upon it would be the
dark squares so night night c 2 nite f2
rook d4 dark square opposite the night
just a single square between it takes
the night forever to attack the rook
from such a position so night here just
double rooks could it maybe consider
doubling rooks right away but just want
to do this 34 okay this night needs to
go and I want to get this pond I'm going
to sack my rook forum this pond if I can
I want I want to just get that pond
could i get that pawn this is this is
this is not good this is not good this
is not good there was something better I
need them I need to do something 20
seconds I just wanted to sack here i was
going to give up some more material just
keep running with this pond I guess I'll
bishop could play here that's that's
something I could be doing Queen takes
pawn pawn push and it can't be caught
canon yeah he can't be caught Queens she
surprisingly she's she's not there to
guard the C 1 square in one move right
this one went down to the wire less than
20 for both of us okay good game meta
plazi I believe this was the first time
we've played let's back up look at it
from your perspective okay some things
to point out are what exactly this right
here I think is a mistake why not play
d4 establish a pond in the center i
already have one you have one that's
challenging but just cement one in the
center d4 is it
d3 allows me to capture and there's none
of this Queen a four to pick it back up
because again he goes into pac-man mode
this is just turning out to be a waste
of time right he took two steps to get
to d4 Bishop here blocking in a central
pawn with the minor piece steer clear of
that and it was still pretty tricky i
don't know if i should have gone into i
don't know if that was the cleanest to
be going in for an imbalance position
like that but i felt i had coordination
you end up getting that pond back or do
you see 5 i'm looking to just open up
the position as soon as you have as soon
as i had your dark square Bishop I'm
looking I'm looking right at your dark
square ponds and I'm looking to strike
at them so that's my main reason behind
night here clearance for the c.c ponder
strike and I still I'm not solving yet
this light square Bishop he still has to
get working but I thought I could
generate some threats I get along this
dog and I'm seeing my queen and I'm
seeing my bishop one day maybe being
able to get out here with check at some
point maybe even be too will fall yeah
this right here I think 83 is fine are
now okay because you're chasing my night
away to square where he wanted to go to
actually you know during the game I was
thinking you know a three is pretty good
but I was forgetting that once on d5 he
is threatening this pond and after this
capture I think there's just absolutely
no compensation if there if there was
even some compensation to begin with I'm
pretty sure right now there's just not
so instead of a 3 if you already even be
in this position I think just recouping
the pond is best just right away grab
that pond and I still have some
difficulties in getting this Bishop
working not so clear as to how I get
them out but after a 3 I think it's just
better now I've saw you you by capturing
you've helped me solve my issue come out
on the classic dog you know
and he's a overprotected on c4 and
there's there's no there's no
compensation at this point I think right
here maybe if I could do it over
actually I'm seeing it right now how
about just dropping the Queen back your
Brooke is still attacked and your night
would be attacked so this would be
better no need to go in for the
imbalance nothing to no need to stir
things up like that and make it a bit
more complicated which is exactly what i
did i had coordination but again
unnecessary and maybe even taking the
night was not needed just allows you
another another pond that i was trying
to track down queen here is very very
active but now my probably got running
here and he just he wasn't able to be
stopped okay good game metaplasia